Twitter is lying to you about what
people watch and I'm gonna prove it to
you that's it that's the tweet
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that won't make you pay eight
dollars for a fake blue check mark Pop
Quiz theorists what's the most watched
show on television right now go on down
to the comments make yourself a guess
and when I reveal the answer later this
episode go and give that comment and
edit to let me know if you are right no
shame and wrong answers by the way
because let me tell you I did not know
if you had given me 10 guesses I would
have never gotten it I have never heard
of this thing before but apparently it
has sequels and spin-offs and no one on
the team has ever watched a fraction of
a single episode anyway I'll give you
the answer later this episode because
that's where the story ends here's where
it begins what does a heartbeat sound
like mighty guys see the new trailer for
Avatar the way of water I did but again
that's because it's my job to try and
stay on top of these things without that
I honestly doubt I would have I have not
heard anyone talking about this movie
online and that immediately interested
me considering that this is the sequel
to literally the highest grossing film
of all time in case you weren't around
her paying attention 13 years ago when
it came out in 2009 Avatar was a huge
deal it was James Cameron's first movie
since his previous highest grossing film
of all time Titanic I'm the king of the
world
not the most humble guy that one I
wonder if we could get him to overpay
for a social media platform that's
hemorrhaging money like an open wound
anyway Avatar was basically Pocahontas
meets the Blue Man Group in space and
yet despite the only significant
challenge to this film status's highest
grossing film of all time coming in the
form of the biggest crossover in
cinematic history I haven't seen a peep
about its sequel over on Twitter in fact
it's trended only twice this year which
is the same number of times that I've
trended and uh not to undersell myself
or anything but let's be honest I am not
the sequel to the biggest movie in in
history that made 2.9 billion dollars at
the box office for context it'd only
take about 14.6 avatars to pay for
Twitter a solid conversion rate to be
sure and this sequel is coming out in
December hold on that soon seriously
what is going on here because my
analytics brain knew that Avatar did
Super well the lack of Twitter chatter
actually made me curious enough to look
deeper into it maybe people just don't
care about this movie but no that
doesn't seem to be the case at all
Avatar 2 has been tracking super well
according to the Quorum a website that
compiles pre-release film data the way
of water has been tracking consistently
high in Awareness interest whether
people will actually pay to see it and
if they'll see it in theaters basically
a ton of people already know about
Avatar 2 and they're willing to pay to
see it on the big screen in fact Avatar
2 has been ahead of black panther
wakanda forever for the entirety of the
year only falling into second place the
week that black panther 2 came out all
of this while marketing for the movie
has barely gotten Beyond a trailer or
two honestly looking at these numbers
had me baffled was the tracking data
just wrong turns out no in truth what
goes viral online isn't necessarily
what's actually popular and the worst
culprit perpetuating all of this is
Twitter what's talked about on Twitter
is not reflective of what people are
actually talking about out in the real
world if you actually look at the
numbers Twitter is borderline lying to
you about what people actually care
about in their TV and film media and I'm
about to prove it to you to start things
off here let's put some things in
perspective we forget just how small a
platform Twitter actually is in 2022
it's estimated that Twitter has 396.5
million users if we're unrealistically
generous to Twitter and assume that none
of those are Bots or people with
multiple accounts that means that just
about five percent of the world's
population has a Twitter account it's
not too shabby don't get me wrong but
for comparison's sake let's just put
that up against YouTube YouTube has an
estimated 2.6 billion monthly active
users and if we again assume that there
are no Bots or users with multiple
accounts that means that just under a
third of the world's population uses
YouTube every month Twitter's 396.5
million figure is their entire user base
not just the people who are using it at
least once a month and believe it or not
YouTube isn't even the biggest fish in
the sea other social media is just as
huge if not bigger Tick Tock has itself
an estimated 1 billion monthly active
users Instagram has 1.4 billion Facebook
has an insane 2.9 billion heck even
Pinterest and Reddit are bigger than
Twitter with 480 million and 430 million
monthly active users respectively what's
more a study from November of 2021 found
that just 25 of Twitter's user base
generates 97 of the website's content
that translates to fewer than 100
million people dictating almost all the
conversation on Twitter and those voices
are massively over represented by
journalists and media personalities who
use Twitter to source and break news I
mean just so many articles have you seen
claiming that people are Furious about
thing and then you click on it and all
they're doing is citing random tweets
from random accounts no actual facts or
Trends or data just the opinion of a
very small slice of one or two random
tweets what's more what users actually
see on Twitter is very tailored to their
own interests just like a lot of social
media Twitter's algorithms create Echo
chambers that only show you the things
that you actively engage with so while
you might think that you're getting
shown a bunch of new and different ideas
and topics all the time you're actually
just getting fed things that Twitter
thinks that you're gonna like and follow
for example if you're really into the
MCU you're gonna get served a lot of MCU
content in your browsing and also a lot
of Guilty Gear Twitter really thinks I'm
gonna be into Guilty Gear for some
reason and the thing is that vocal
minority on Twitter is driving a lot of
the decision making that's happening in
and around Hollywood sometimes the
changes are for the better like when
Sonic the Hedgehog's design got
completely overhauled thanks to the
social media backlash against ugly Sonic
but sometimes they're for the worst like
when Star Wars crumbled under the social
media pressure brought upon by The Last
Jedi to make the confusing unfocused and
apologetic mess that was the rise of
Skywalker and we're not just talking
about the decisions inside the movies
themselves that are being affected by
online discourse but what gets greenlit
in the first place the fantasy book
series Aragon just got picked up by
Disney thanks specifically to a fandom
surge on Twitter Daredevil actor Charlie
Cox has repeatedly said that the save
Daredevil Twitter campaign saved his
career after corporate disagreement got
the show canceled on Netflix morbius was
re-released in theaters because clearly
everyone Meme and the thing on Twitter
wanted a chance to morb all over the
theater again and of course there's the
Snyder cut of Justice League Where Heads
of the company went on record to say
quote since I got here 14 months ago the
chant to release the Snyder cut has been
a daily drum beat in our offices and
inboxes while the fans have asked and we
are thrilled to finally deliver the
ironic part of all of that is in the
aftermath it came out the whole released
the Snyder cut campaign was likely
driven by Snyder himself in an army of
bots just to get fans riled up as an act
of revenge against a Warner Brothers
regardless those are just a few examples
of how this relatively small social
media platform made up of a very vocal
minority has historically had a huge
Sway in the entertainment industry so
with all of that mind we wanted to find
out just how skewed these results can
get we needed a way to compare what
people were actually talking about on
Twitter to what was actually being
watched beyond the Twitter sphere now
finding data about what's trending on
Twitter is actually pretty easy several
websites have archived that exact
information by time and date while
finding exactly what to compare it
against is kind of difficult can't
exactly just look at box office numbers
to gauge success anymore getting big
bucks at theaters is great don't get me
wrong it's just not the only metric that
matters anymore so we turn to Parrot
analytics a data company who made their
name with a software that's able to
track the true demand for movies TV and
digital media they do this by running a
complex algorithm that takes a lot of
variables into account how many people
watched in what demographics for how
long how does this product Trend in
search results where does it fall in the
news cycle even stuff like how much
money are people willing to spend end on
this thing and what is the tone of the
search results news coverage now that is
a lot of data to throw into an
alchemical analytics concoction and some
of it did make me squint my eyes
suspiciously but you know what I think
that it offers a valuable insight into
what people are watching and it can act
as a kind of North Star for our analysis
here today looking at their top 10 list
of most in-demand overall movie as of
July 2022 the results were eye-opening
to put it mildly sure a lot of the list
is what you'd expect Spider-Man at the
top absolutely expected the Batman in
the top five sure because Batman but
then he had some surprises Venom Let
There Be Carnage earn the number two
most in-demand spot that tracks
considering it was the third highest
grossing film of 2021 but the day it was
released Venom 2 trended for only 90
minutes it only got itself 11 850 tweets
now compare that to the number one spot
of Spider-Man the day no way home
released Spider-Man trended with a
maximum 398
000 tweets its longest Trend streak ran
for seven and a half hours meanwhile
Marvel and Tom Holland were also
breaking into the most trending tab with
a hundred and eighty two thousand and
131 500 tweets respectively Venom 2 was
a tenth of those no one was talking
about this thing over on Twitter despite
it being one of the most successful
highest earning movies of last year
meanwhile Zack Snyder's Justice League
shows the exact opposite pattern on the
day it was announced some variation of
Snyder or Snyder cut peaked on trending
with 170 000 tweets and a streak of
seven hours on the day it was released
it peaked with 332
000 tweets and had an insane streak of
19 hours I mean that's on par with
Spider-Man numbers and yet despite all
of this online chatter and this massive
multi-month-long fan campaign it was
only watched by 2.2 million homes the
first week with reports noting that just
36 percent of people who watched it
actually finished it the last one I'll
call out for now is the eternals on the
day of its release eternals trended on
Twitter with just just over 99 000
tweets and a streak of four and a half
hours not bad by any means but nowhere
close to Black Widow which trended with
nearly double the amount of tweets 193
000 and a streak of seven and a half
hours on its release date and yet
eternals managed to outperform its rival
MCU release in all metrics in short
Twitter's Trends just don't seem to
consistently align with what people are
actually watching what people actually
care about which brings us back to the
question that I started off with what is
the actual biggest show on TV right now
believe it or not according to Nielsen
ratings the most watched show on
television right now by a huge margin is
this series called Yellowstone it's a
gritty drama about modern Cowboys and
Rural Ranch politics with lots and lots
of fights the report claims that 13 of
all households watching TV while
Yellowstone was on were watching the
show this translated to a staggering 9.3
million viewers during its season 4
finale in January of 2022. literally the
only thing that beats yellow Stone on
broadcast TV is football the hand egg
one not the European football even more
incredibly the show doesn't even air on
one of the mainstream channels like NBC
or CBS instead it's on the Paramount
Network which used to be called Spike TV
home of CSI reruns and Deadliest Warrior
while digging into this data at first I
thought these viewership numbers had to
be Juiced in some way the views coming
out of TV ratings can sometimes be
inflated so I had to triple check myself
but apparently the series and its
creators have made so much money for
Paramount that they're going all in on
the Yellowstone IP it spun off into a
prequel called 1883 which itself is
getting a spin-off about the real-life
Western hero bass Reeves it's also
getting a prequel sequel called 1923
starring Harrison Ford and Helen Mirren
and another contemporary spin-off called
four sixes set in Texas instead of
Montana there's basically an entire
Yellowstone Cinematic Universe and no
one on team theorist knew about this
thing not one but you know who did know
about it are parents people that aren't
on Twitter yeah one of our team members
actually asked their mom if they watched
Yellowstone and got this text message
back love it Cowboys are cute apparently
everyone they knew would watch it and
talk about it even the dogs would bark
whenever a horse would show up on screen
and as you might expect looking at
Google Trends data the show crushes not
even black panther can catch it the week
of its release but now look at the
Twitter data from when that finale aired
back in January practically nothing it
barely broke into Twitter's trending
list maxing out at 13 000 tweets with
the longest streak of just three and a
half hours basically this was barely a
blip on Twitter's radar there seems to
be this massive audience of apparent
Boomers and older gen xers that are
really underrepresented on Twitter and
therefore the resulting trends that
people talk about on YouTube and twitch
and whatever really this sort of silent
majority when it comes to what people
are actually consuming is fascinating
probably deserves its own Theory at some
point in short as Twitter Teeters on the
verge of collapse right now I wanted to
make this episode to point out the echo
chamber that it keeps a lot of its users
in and the false perception that it
gives about the world of content around
us I think a lot of its users assumed
that this was the new water cooler the
neutral place that would serve as an
accurate representation of everything
happening around us a place where people
would go and gather to chat about their
favorite TV shows movies Sports politics
whatever but no it is not that it feeds
you what it thinks you want to hear and
prevents you from learning about things
that are important to the people around
you sometimes those things are trivial
like a show about hunky Cowboys but
oftentimes it's stuff that's a whole lot
more important and so regardless of the
platform's future I'd warn you to not
fall into the Trap that the Disney's and
Warner Brothers did making decisions off
a few tweets coming from a very vocal
subset of the most extreme users or
Worse basing your opinions off an army
of bots created by Deep pocketed users
with ulterior motives now if you'll
excuse me I've gotta go see how rip
Sheriff investigation goes after his
accident with those tourists it's a
Yellowstone thing you wouldn't
understand or maybe now you will but hey
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and cut
[Music]